[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer le la
soirée même dans les Yvelines avec au
programme des infos de l'actualité des
Infopratique et aussi des idées de
sortie voici le programme de ce 17
octobre
plusieurs syndicats appellent à une
mobilisation ce mardi 18 octobre une
grève qui concerne toujours les
raffineries mais aussi les transports
publics l'éducation ou encore la santé
quels sont les perturbations à prévoir
le point à suivre dans cette édition
large page consacrée au championnat du
monde de cyclisme sur piste la
compétition se tenait de mercredi à
dimanche au Vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yvelines la France termine à la
troisième place execo au tableau des
médailles avec trois titres remportés
que penser de ces résultats on posera la
question à notre invité et puis cet
événement était l'occasion de tester de
se tester avant Paris 2024 l'enceinte 5
continents accueillera les épreuves des
Jeux Olympiques dans moins de deux ans
quel bilan en tiré focus également sur
les bénévoles qui ont été très nombreux
sur ces Mondiaux
à suivre également avec vous célinechal
bonsoir les informations du jour on
reviendra notamment sur l'hommage à
Samuel Paty qui était donné hier
dimanche à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine 2
jours après l'assassinat du professeur
oui un millier de personnes se sont
réunies à proximité du collège du bois
d'aulne à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine pour
lui rendre hommage c'était
l'établissement où Samuel Paty
enseignait et c'était 2 ans jour pour
jour bien sûr après son assassinat on a
également un invité je vous le disais
dans les titres c'est Jean-Michel
Richford bonsoir bonsoir vice-président
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
président également du club de cyclides
de Vélizy on va parler avec vous de ces
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste ça y est c'est terminé
quelle première réaction est-ce que vous
êtes content est-ce que au contraire
vous êtes triste de terminer ces
championnats du monde mais triste
lorsqu'on est au cœur d'une organisation
telle que les champions du monde on
aimerait que ça dure mais bon tout a une
fin et bon c'était des championnats du
monde je pense très réussi très réussi
au niveau populaire au niveau de
l'organisation et pour l'équipe de
France c'était également une belle
réussite on fera le bilan avec vous dans
un instant il y avait deux hommes qui
étaient présents sur ces cinq jours de
compétition Vélodrome national un homme
qui a été présent tous les jours c'est
Michael et nuit Doro bonsoir bonsoir la
rédaction de TV 78 oui également
peut-être soulagement que ce soit
terminé au niveau au niveau du travail
parce que il vous avez travaillé quand
même pendant 5 jours
mais on reste au travail mais cinq jours
exceptionnels Grégory et cinq jours où
il y a eu des médailles françaises il y
a eu des records il y avait 51 pays qui
étaient présents donc oui c'est du
travail mais c'est avant tout du plaisir
Nicolas dandry également bonsoir bonsoir
qui a été présent sur quelques soirées
également au Vélodrome on reviendra avec
vous forcément sur la victoire ce titre
exceptionnel de Mathilde gros ça a
ouvert d'ailleurs le compteur des titres
pour l'équipe de France sur ces Mondiaux
oui puis des émotions comme on aime en
vivre et comme le seul le sport peut en
faire vivre et on viendra sur cette
famille et la famille gros qui soutient
à chaque compétition sa fille sa petite
fille voir sa nièce Mathilde gros qui a
été championne du monde de la vitesse
individuelle on verra sur cette grande
émotion tout à l'heure dans le 7 8 avant
tout cela un petit coup d'œil à la météo
la météo bien sûr de demain mardi à 18
octobre et nous fêterons les Lucs pour
cette journée des températures et des
conditions homogènes sur tout le
territoire ce sera un nuageux le matin
compté avec 15 degrés dans les Yvelines
le soleil qui devrait faire quelques
apparitions dans l'après-midi avec
toujours quelques nuages il fera 20
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 19 degrés à
Houdan Versailles Rambouillet des
températures assez hautes pour une
mi-octobre qui devrait se maintenir
toute la semaine et la pluie et même
annoncée pour vendredi
[Musique]
c'est l'heure des informations du jour
avec Céline Charle et on en parlait tout
à l'heure d'abord se rassemblement la
mémoire du professeur Samuel Paty
assassiné par un terroriste le 16
octobre 2020 c'était à proximité de son
collège à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine oui 2
ans après sa mort un hommage à Samuel
Paty Dubois d'aulne à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et lui habitant
parents et collégiens ont répondu
présent c'est une grève qui semble sans
fin ce lundi les grévistes des
raffineries de Total énergie on
reconduit les blocages sur 5 Sites la
ministre de la transition énergétique
Agnès panier renacher qui était en
visite ce matin dans un dépôt de
Gennevilliers à cependant annoncé le
départ de 200 camions citerne dans la
matinée pour approvisionner
l'Île-de-France dans la même lignée
demain mardi 18 octobre un mouvement de
grève générale est lancé par la CGT la
SNCF la RATP et l'éducation nationale
seront notamment concernées mais les
prévisions complètes à suivre dans un
instant j'ajoute sur la thématique
autour de l'hommage à Samuel Paty que
vendredi et ce lundi des temps endommage
ont été tenus dans tous les
établissements de France collège et
lycée de France à un moment de
recueillement auquel n'a pas pu assister
la presse parce que l'éducation
nationale a voulu réserver ses temps aux
élèves et aux équipes pédagogiques dans
l'actualité également Céline on en
parlait aussi tout à l'heure on parle de
sport avec ces mondiaux de cyclisme sur
piste qui se sont achevés hier au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
est-ce que le bilan des Français est bon
c'est plutôt un bon bilan avec cette
médaille dont trois en or la France
termine troisième nation au tableau
d'honneur derrière les Pays-Bas et les
l'Italie à égalité avec l'Allemagne
Mathilde de gros 23 ans notamment obtenu
la médaille d'or dans l'épreuve de
vitesse lors aussi pour Marie divine
Kouame sur le 500 m à seulement 20 ans
sport encore mais une déception cette
fois-ci ils avaient fait un parcours
exceptionnel l'année dernière avec une
demi-finale en Coupe de France le FC
Versailles a été éliminé ce dimanche
après-midi au sixième tour il recevait
le Red Star FC lors d'un match qui s'est
terminé un à un les deux équipes se sont
départagées lors de la séance de tir au
but en faveur de l'équipe adverse de son
côté la es Poissy continue l'aventure et
se qualifient pour le septième tour
après son match 1-0 face à
sainte-genevièvement
juste une petite réaction Michael
journaliste sport de la rédaction du
bonheur pour Poissy mais forcément de la
déception il y avait eu une demi-finale
pour le FC Versailles
enfin ce week-end avait lieu également
un salon on a vu quelques images
apparaître exactement ce weekend avait
lieu le salon du concours culinaire
national les parcours du goût à la Ferme
du Manet de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
organisé par le ministère de la Justice
plusieurs jeunes suivis par la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse ce
sont affrontés aux fourneaux et ont pu
rencontrer plusieurs grands chefs on
écoute Louise petit Renaud marraine du
salon sur les bénéfices de cette
opération j'ai vraiment voilà envie de
soit de l'ordre de confiance de leur
redonner confiance s'ils l'ont perdu
leur dire que je suis là que je peux les
écouter et puis échanger peut-être les
valeurs que j'ai les valeurs de respect
du travail
de la solidarité
interviews ont été réalisés lors de ce
salon elles sont à retrouver un plus
tard sur TV 78 merci Céline pour toutes
ces informations
[Musique]
on vous en parlez l'une des informations
de 7 journées c'est la grève qui est
prévue demain une grève
interprofessionnelle à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats CGT fofsu et
solidaire conséquences de nombreuses
perturbations sont à prévoir et
notamment dans les transports interview
avec Mathieu bol Reda secrétaire du
syndicat CGT cheminot de Versailles
[Musique]
deux raisons de problématiques la
première évidemment une problématique
salaire nous avons 8 ans de blocage des
salaires suite à la ligne grève en
juillet nous avons eu 1,4%
d'augmentation de salaire qui est
ridicule au regard des huit années de
blocage et au regard de l'inflation que
l'INSEE nous avons plus de 10% pour pour
cette année la SNCF une entreprise qui a
fait plus de 2 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices et la deuxième raison c'est
l'effroi les mois qui a déclenché chez
les cheminots et chez les milliers de
salariés en France le recours de
réquisition de la part du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire une réponse uniquement
policière à la grève beaucoup de
brutalité la réquisition c'est pas juste
un acte administratif c'est des
policiers des gendarmes qui viennent
chez vous éventuellement vous menottes
devant vos familles pour vous faire
tourner au travail
[Musique]
alors c'est extrêmement suivi notamment
à la conduite mais aussi chez les
aiguilleurs et on a déjà les annonces de
perturbation pour mardi
donc pour demain c'est plus de 50% des
circulations qui sont supprimées sur la
ligne C qui est la ligne sur laquelle je
conduis et aussi sur les lignes un qui
sont représentés dans les Yvelines donc
c'est un mouvement qui est large qui est
fort et qui s'est organisé à l'arrache
en quelques heures en quelques jours
donc qui montre que vraiment il y a un
émoi très important des cheminots sur la
question des salaires et bien sûr sur la
question de la défense du droit de grève
la Fédération CGT des cheminots et ses
syndicats CGT en local ont mis à
disposition des cheminots des préavis
pouvant être reconduits de façon à ce
que les cheminots décident par eux-mêmes
en assemblée générale mais je peux vous
annoncer déjà que la direction annonce
déjà sur ma ligne la ligne C un S3
c'est-à-dire un service de grève avec
seulement deux trains sur trois en
circulation pour le mercredi alors même
que la grève de demain n'a pas commencé
et que les assemblées générales n'ont
pas eu lieu donc il n'est absolument pas
exclure que le mouvement se continue si
la direction de la SNCF ne fait pas un
pas vers les cheminots pour négocier sur
la base des revendications sur les
augmentations de salaires
[Musique]
la solution Jean-Michel rifford demain
c'est peut-être de prendre son vélo pour
éviter les grèves absolument avec un
petit imperméable mais le vélo est une
excellente solution est-ce que vous avez
pris vos dispositions messieurs lorsque
il y a aussi on disait une grève dans
les raffineries c'est aussi difficile de
faire le plein est-ce que vous avez de
l'essence dans la voiture pour venir
demain au travail on pourra compter sur
vous quand même demain oui c'est sûr de
après demain il y a encore après demain
je ne suis pas sûr mais bon je vais
faire le maximum pour je suis à peu près
la moitié du plan donc il faut
s'organiser il faut s'organiser et être
patient surtout donc pas forcément de
solution de repli côté transport il y a
le vélo tout de même mais côté transport
ingrève qui s'annonce difficile avec
nous de nombreuses perturbations pour
cette journée du mardi à 18 octobre avec
dans les transports vous allez le voir
les prévisions pour demain sur le RER A
et le RER B qui passent dans les
Yvelines bien sûr trois trains sur 4
annoncés à noter que sur le RER B sur la
partie nord c'est à dire à partir de
gare du Nord ce sera un train sur deux
qui est assuré demain avec
l'interconnexion à Gare du Nord qui sera
toujours assurée sur les autres en ligne
qui passe dans les Yvelines le RER C
comptez intrins sur deux un train sur
trois pour les lignes du Transilien JL
et U et sur la ligne N du Transilien ce
sera un train sur deux c'est pour le
moment des prévisions qui sont annoncées
pour cette journée de demain noter
également que des perturbations sont
annoncées sur le réseau des bus un
climat social tendu et depuis le 3
octobre d'ailleurs un côté bus les
salariés de Keolis autocar de Lyon sont
en grève illimitées il dénonce une
dégradation de leur condition de travail
de leurs acquis sociaux depuis le
transfert du transporteur Transdev pour
Keolis les employés des dépôts du nord
des Yvelines se sont retrouvés à
Verneuil-sur-Seine regardez pour
protester contre la direction gré
illimité pour 120 salariés Keolis dans
des dépôts du secteur Montesson voici
les Mureaux Maisons-Laffitte les
employés ont cessé le travail le jeudi
13 octobre afin d'alerter contre
l'ouverture à la concurrence de leur
ligne de bus repris par la société de
transport Keolis en août 2021 il
constate une dégradation de leurs acquis
sociaux on était chez Transdev ça se
passait super bien la qualité de service
était au rendez-vous les salaires
étaient au rendez-vous l'organisation de
travail c'est fait pendant des années ça
a été conçu pendant des années ouverture
à la concurrence les règles soumis par
Madame Pécresse on rase tout on
recommence tout à zéro l'impact qu'il y
a derrière tout ça et ben ça va aller
chercher dans dans la masse salariale
dans les conditions de travail
l'organisation de travail on demande
donc une augmentation des salaires on
demande le maintien des primes pour
l'ensemble des salariés et on demande
également que la politique sociale soit
maintenue avec des conditions sociales
de rigueur les salariés de kiolis
autocar de Lyon affirme que le
transporteur mis une politique
antisociale il ne souhaite pas que les
accords d'entreprise historiques pris au
sein de Transdev soit rediscutés pour un
accord de substitution le 1er novembre
2022 ont tous nos accords d'entreprises
vont tomber donc ils vont s'effacer les
négociations ça fait plus de
six mois on n'arrive pas à avancer on
nous donne voilà des miettes pour
l'instant c'est des miettes alors qu'on
demande pas plus de ce qu'on avait avant
c'est de profiter de l'opportunité de
l'ouverture à la concurrence pour
déstabiliser toute l'organisation des
territoire et puis surtout pour mettre
en concurrence pas les entreprises mais
les salariés les uns contre les autres
contactez la direction de Keolis autocar
de Lyon n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer elle
indique cependant maintenir le dialogue
avec les représentants syndicaux afin de
trouver au plus vite une issue et
rétablir le service de transport
journée donc de grève
interprofessionnelle demain mercredi à
18 octobre avec les transports qui
seront perturbés d'autres perturbations
à prévoir également dans les secteurs de
l'éducation et de la santé sur
l'éducation les syndicatsu et SUD
éducation sont également ce sont joint à
cet appel à la grève côté santé c'est le
syndicat assez FDT Santé Sociaux donc
noté qu'il y aura peut-être également
des perturbations dans ces deux secteurs
[Musique]
51 délégations 420 athlètes 22 titres
décernés sur cinq jours de compétition
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste ont
pris fin hier à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines coup d'oeil au
tableau des médailles avec les Pays-Bas
qui terminent en tête avec quatre
médailles d'or tout comme tout comme
l'Italie qui est deuxième mais avec 10
médailles au total 4 en argent de en
bronze la France elle termine à la
troisième place execo avec cette
médaille trois en or trois en argent et
un bronze en 2015 il y avait également
eu cette médailles mais cinq titres au
total de manière générale Jean-Michel
richefort avant qu'on vienne sur les
résultats précis des Français est-ce que
vous diriez que c'est mondiaux 2022 sont
un bon crus oui c'est mondiaux sont
forcément un bon crus l'équipe de France
était quand même attendu il est
difficile de transformer et de scorer à
dîner à domicile et bon dans l'ensemble
je pense qu'on a eu une très belle
équipe de France avec avec des jeunes
c'est pas précisément
qu'on attendait et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle mais pour certains mais
dans l'ensemble oui ça a été un bon cru
vous qui avez vécu Michael les Mondiaux
en 2015 ou des alliés couverts déjà pour
tv78 c'est mondiaux 2022 si vous faites
le comparatif en terme de résultats en
terme de résultat on parlera de
l'événement après en terme de résultat
en 2015 c'est 5 médailles d'or et 2 de
bronze là c'est trois médailles d'or 3
médailles d'argent et une debout
toujours 7 au total exactement donc
c'est forcément pour moi moins bien
parce que avec 5 médailles d'or la
France avait surperformé en 2015 là
c'est quand même pas mal 3 médailles
d'or mais un peu moins bien qu'en 2015
oui mais le débat est lancé cinq
médailles dans les disciplines
olympiques et ça c'est très important
parce que nous vient pas que l'objectif
majeur c'est 2024 à domicile et ces cinq
médailles sont très très pas
encourageantes pour la direction
technique nationale pour Christophe
Manal DTN et ça il faut le souligner
parce que les disciplines olympiques se
sont quand même les disciplines où il
est le plus difficile d'aller chercher
les podiums et les médailles et là on
est déjà sur 2024 effectivement
encourageant à moins de 2 ans des JO
Nicolas dandry bah oui alors je posais
la question est-ce que c'est le l'effet
de l'arrivée de Florian Rousseau qui
s'occupe uniquement de la partie
olympique le fait qu'il y ait 5
médailles sur les disciplines directeur
du programme olympique c'est un nouveau
titre qui a été créé justement à
l'occasion de ces JO Florian a contribué
mais il faut associer Grégory Baugé
également la vitesse et l'entraîneur
national de la vitesse du sprint et
ces deux c'est de sportif de très haut
niveau font bénéficier de leur
expérience des des grands rendez-vous
internationaux à cette jeune équipe et
je pense que là c'est déclencheur on va
regarder plus précisément le tableau des
médailles françaises je vous le disais
avec trois titres un titre à la vitesse
individuelle pour Mathilde gros le 500
mètres pour Mary divine Kwame et le
madison pour donabane Grondin et
Benjamin Thomas 3 médailles d'argent
pour Clara Coconi et Valentine Fortin en
Madison Benjamin Thomas l'Omnium et
Melvin landerno contre la montre et
enfin une médaille de bronze pour cette
délégation française à la poursuite
femme par équipe on parlait de Florian
Rousseau vous avez tendu à la petite
perche Nicolas dandry ben on va écouter
justement le bilan dressé par Florian
Rousseau je rappelle qu'il est le
directeur du programme olympique premier
rôle je suis arrivé on a joué les
premiers rôles il y a cette médailles
mais faut pas oublier aussi il y a des
quatrième et des 5e place pour nous
c'était important ce championnat du
monde pour notre objectif notre objectif
reste les jeux mais c'était un marqueur
important dans la dynamique de réussite
on apprend de nos réussites aussi de nos
déceptions il y a eu des déceptions mais
nos équipes sont compétitives nos
coureurs étaient compétitifs
une belle dynamique dans l'équipe donc
Jean-Michel vous disiez encourageant
donc si on regarde par rapport au bilan
la question que je pose à Mickael 5
titres en 2015 3 en 2022 il y a pas de
déception à avoir donc il y a pas de
déception alors il y a toujours des
déceptions on attendait par exemple
Sébastien Vigier Sébastien Vigier qui
bon victime d'une chute dans dans la
série
il a été handicapé en vitesse sinon
si tout se passe bien pour Sébastien il
doit monter sur le podium en vitesse
même chose pour notre vitesse par équipe
victime d'un faux départ donc il les a
perturbés bon ils étaient podiumables
bien sûr et là bon avec un petit grain
de sable et puis la médaille échappe
voilà c'est c'est le sport on a sûrement
pas l'image mais c'est peut-être l'une
des images un peu choc je sais pas si on
peut dire choc sur ces cinq jours
Sébastien Vigier il s'est fait dans le
jargon une petite pizza une escalope
ouais il s'est brûlé en tombant et
surtout que il s'est blessé après avoir
terminé la course c'est c'est ça le plus
dommage dans l'histoire il s'est blessé
dans dans le virage juste après la ligne
d'arrivée il est tombé je crois que
c'est hoverland si je me trompe pas qui
qui le percute et il tombe et forcément
une grosse brûlure au niveau de la
cuisse qui l'a empêché de dormir dans la
dans la nuit du coup forcément moins de
récupération dans une échéance comme les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste c'est quasiment c'est compliqué
scandale lui-même en fait interview
juste après cette chute c'est sur nos
réseaux sociaux et vous aviez pu nickel
l'interviewer du coup est-ce que c'est
une bonne stratégie Jean-Michel de ne
pas se fixer d'objectif avant c'est
mondiaux c'était aussi la ligne affichée
par Florian Rousseau pas d'objectif
affiché peut-être que ça a mis moins de
pression sur cette équipe de France
aussi moins de pression une équipe de
France quand même jeune une équipe de
France en devenir et bon bien sûr ça
sert à rien surtout fallait protéger sur
protéger Mathilde de gros sur des
échéances
dans précédentes on lui avait mis
beaucoup de pression là elle a été
protégée et voilà avec tout le toute la
réussite
combien qu'on lui a connu et je pense
que là la franchi un cap en dominant les
Allemands qui étaient les grandes
favorites les grandes favorites et
surtout en sprint lorsque on prend
l'ascendant sur l'adversaire c'est
vraiment de bonne augure pour les
échéances à venir notamment pour les
Jeux olympiques mais après il faut pas
s'endormir sur sur ces lauriers
on le disait c'est elle qui a ouvert le
compteur des médailles d'or pas le
compteur des médailles mais le compteur
des médailles d'or sur ces mondiaux avec
une victoire flamboyante à la vitesse
individuelle c'était vendredi sacré
championne du monde Jean-Michel le
rappelait devant les deux Allemands
d'Emma in the et Léa Sophie Friedrich
premier sacre mondial dans l'absolu
également pour la jeune piste hard
écoutez sa réaction
s'entraîne ici donc c'est pour tous les
autres athlètes pour tout le staff pour
la fédé c'est vraiment ouais c'est pour
eux quoi c'est top c'est je pouvais pas
rêver mieux ce soir
je redonne la parole nickel sur Mathilde
de gros celle qui a sonné un peu le
réveil français sur ces monuments de
pied tout à fait après Jean-Michel elle
est à l'avancée masquée sur ses
championnats du monde avec pas donné
d'objectifs particuliers pour pour ma
type de groupe mais il fallait qu'à un
moment un autre elle gagne c'était là
dans ce vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines elle avait échoué aux Jeux
Olympiques on l'attendait beaucoup on
l'annonce comme la future pépite du
cyclisme français elle a commencé le
cyclisme très tard 16 17 ans était elle
vient du basketball assez testé sur sur
un vélo un jour on lui a dit tu as du
talent lance-toi sur le cyclisme sur
piste j'ai dit du sport finalement j'ai
mis du sport exactement finalement elle
performe elle performait pas au niveau
mondial pour l'instant elle a fait
quelques titres notamment européens des
titres français également mais au niveau
mondial pour l'instant ça coincer un peu
et là on sent qu'il y a peut-être eu le
déclic pour Mathilde de gros mais on
sent peut-être un avant après mon Dieu
on va parler de Mathilde gros et du clan
gros avec Nicolas on a l'impression
qu'il y aura un avant et un après
peut-être que c'est une nouvelle mative
de gros là qui est lancée euh tout droit
vers ces certainement mais c'est le
fruit d'un travail acharné pour avoir
été témoin de plusieurs séances
d'entraînement notamment avec Grégory
Baugé je pense que là le travail à un
moment donné ou un autre paix et là elle
a pris une dimension sans aucun doute
une dimension supplémentaire Nicolas
pour l'avoir regardé un peu dans sa
manière d'appréhender chaque course on
voit qu'elle avait un visage assez fermé
il y a des photos qui sont assez
impressionnantes sur les réseaux sociaux
où on la voit juste avant la course
chercher le regard de ses adversaires du
regard il est exceptionnel et puis on
voit qu'elle était beaucoup plus
déterminée
à se plaquer limite de faire un mini
haka quoi le se claquer les cuisses se
claquer les pectoraux c'est on voyait
plus de tête détermination je sais pas à
votre avis Jean-Michel
absolument très rapidement et la prix la
prime dimension effectivement et là
surtout en sprint où il faut prendre
l'ascendant sur l'adversaire même avant
le match et je pense qu'il y a une
grosse part de bluff aussi d'habitude
c'est elle qui subissait le bluff des
adversaires et là finalement c'est elle
qui a pris l'ascendant tout simplement
les cons on s'en souvient une
demi-finale qui s'est joué à la belle
d'ailleurs on aurait pu croire que ça
aurait pu la fatiguer pour la finale il
n'en a pas été ainsi et Mathilde de gros
c'est imposé en vitesse individuelle
première médaille d'or française il y en
a eu trois en tout on va parler des
autres médailles d'or dans un instant
mais vendredi Nicolas vous avez suivi
avec plus d'attention cette course de
Mathilde de gros en vitesse individuelle
et aux côtés de sa famille qui était
présente en nombre en tribunes jusqu'à
son sacre et à la remise de la médaille
d'or effectivement Grégory alors je vous
ai dit j'étais dans la 2 centrale au
début au niveau des premières
demi-finales et puis au deuxième
demi-finale je je suis allé voir la
famille qui était en tribune et je vais
commencer par cette séquence très forte
Grégory Mathilde de gros vient de
remporter sa finale face à l'Allemande
Léa Sophie Friedrich la piste de 23 ans
et championne du monde de vitesse
individuelle elle va rejoindre sa
famille en tribune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors sur ces images dans l'ordre vous
venez de voir la maman Séverine le frère
la grand-mère Hélène et le papa Maurice
gros la team gros est reconnaissable
avec leur chapeau blanc sur la tête dans
les tribunes et leurs t-shirt avec un
gros g après ce moment fort en émotion
Grégory il y a eu aussi la cérémonie de
remise des médailles et là j'étais à
côté de la marraine de Mathilde gros et
de sa grand-mère et il aime regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un clan soudé Nicolas et sa famille est
présente aussi sur toutes les autres
compétitions elle était là déjà
auparavant oui effectivement Grégory il
pousse très très fort derrière elle et
vous dites qu'on était on l'avait suivi
en fait auparavant puisque dès 2018 lors
d'une coupe d'une étape de coupe du
monde au Vélodrome national c'était en
octobre 2018 et bien j'avais suivi la
famille gros et je peux vous dire que
leur encouragement région est résonnait
déjà beaucoup dans le dos me 56 noir
ils sont à fond et encore si vous avez
vu mes grands-parents vous avez dû les
voir aussi enfin des fois ils avouent
ils me disent mais on est malade quoi
surtout en Kirin en vitesse c'est vrai
qu'il y a de la pression mais il y a un
peu moins de chance de chute donc ouais
franchement ça a eux aussi ils disent en
fait on vit le truc avec toi quoi donc
c'est énorme moi tout ce que je retiens
c'est qu'elle rentre dans le carré des
quatre vraiment
concurrente magnifique quoi et ça c'est
pour elle c'est une j'ai vu
vieux
mérite alors là on vient de voir à la
grand-mère c'était en 2018 elle pleurait
déjà elle était déjà très émue des
performances de sa petite fille juste
une question Jean-Michel le poids du
soutien de la famille de ses amis c'est
important pour un sportif de haut niveau
c'est très important d'avoir la famille
derrière parce que un athlète de haut
niveau de très haut niveau bon
quelquefois bon il est seul dans la
bulle et il y a des moments de forêt
mais il y a des moments difficiles à
passer et lorsqu'on a sa famille
derrière la comme on le voit c'est le
team
s'appropulse sa propulse c'est c'est
évident alors le deuxième titre est
arrivé samedi on a eu un vendredi un
samedi un dimanche c'est Mary divine
Kouame à 20 ans seulement qui est déjà
championne du monde elle est sacrée dans
l'épreuve du 500 mètres devant
l'Allemande Emma Insee et la Chinoise
you Fongo en 32 secondes 835 centièmes
écoutez sa réaction
je voulais remercier tout le public
français toute ma famille qui est dans
les tribunes j'ai passé un moment
incroyable que j'oublierai jamais de
venir champion du monde à 20 ans sur le
500 m c'est incroyable ça promet pour la
suite je suis tellement fière je pensais
jamais ressentir ce genre d'émotion et
c'est un froid diable je le souhaite à
tous les sportifs du monde je le
souhaite à même les noms sportives de
ressentir ça à la fierté des parents la
fierté de la famille des amis de
l'équipe du coach de tout le monde et
voilà je suis trop contente
ce qui est dommage Jean-Michel richefort
c'est que c'est une discipline non
olympique donc on verra pas la
discipline du 500 métro aux JO mais vous
le disiez tout à l'heure c'est la
jeunesse au pouvoir là avec c'est
mondiaux la jeunesse au pouvoir moi ça
fait d'autant plus plaisir que Marie
divine je l'ai vu sur les épreuves
régionales je l'ai vu je l'ai vu grandir
je l'ai vu progresser et puis là là
c'est c'est tout le bonheur du monde si
il fume exprimer ainsi là très
communicative à la communiquer le
bonheur à tout le vélodrome ça c'est non
seulement c'est mérité mais il y avait
quelque chose magique
une vraie fraîcheur je trouve avec Marie
divine Kouame je la connaissais pas plus
que ça je la voyais de temps en temps
dans ce vélo donc de national de 50 ans
en Yvelines je lui ai parlé quelquefois
mais pas pas plus que ça et là vraiment
j'ai découvert une une joie de vivre une
fille très expressive qui a tout donné
sur la piste et ça c'est vu ça s'est vu
elle était libérée elle a notamment par
les Grégory Baugé qui l'a poussé à se
dépasser c'est ces derniers mois elle
nous a dit qu'elle en avait bavé mais
qu'elle pourrait le refaire tous les
jours vu là je vois que ça procuré bravo
à elle et le dernier titre je le disais
c'était donc dimanche avec Donavan
Grondin et et Benjamin Thomas ils ont
été en bronze à Tokyo et là cette
fois-ci le le duo c'est imposé au
Madison je vous rappelle un 200 tours 50
km entrecoupé de de 20 sprints devant
les Britanniques devant les Belges je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
leur réaction également c'est parti
c'est pas comme ça je vais le souvenir
de Tokyo on a passé la ligne on voyait
on se souvient plus s'est passé mais là
on a pu vraiment bien savourer assurer
et
c'était c'est vraiment exceptionnel les
derniers tours on pense même plus à la
course on est juste à profiter à kiffer
la progression même la confirmation pour
ce duo qui était déjà en bronze à Tokyo
et en plus ils ont maté la concurrence
18 points d'avance au final on a dû au
magique ils étaient en super forme ils
ont mille-feu au Vélodrome c'était
vraiment l'apothéose mais c'est un duo
il se trouve il passe les relais les
yeux fermés et c'est c'est exceptionnel
quoi ils ont pris encore une une
dimension là c'était du grand art avec
une opposition de très haut niveau
lorsqu'on bat les Britanniques les
Belges sur une Américaine là c'est
formidable mais là on tient vraiment une
paire en or un dernier mot côté sportif
si on peut revoir le tableau des
médailles françaises sur ces Mondiaux je
le disais à côté de ces trois titres il
y a aussi trois médailles d'argent je
rappelle un Clara cocooning Valentine
Fortin ou mad Benjamin Thomas l'Omnium
Melville Landerneau au contre-la-montre
et une médaille de bronze pour la
poursuite femme par équipe on a parlé
des grosses satisfactions quelles sont
les déceptions pour vous sur sur ces
Mondiaux la vitesse par équipe peut-être
oui la vitesse par les premiers jours le
premier jour bon n'oublions pas que
cette équipe
voilà a été potentiellement médaillable
et puis bon il y a eu un faux départ qui
a perturbé
Timmy gillions mais ils l'ont pas
entendu donc le coup de pistolet mais ça
arrive ça arrive quasiment fait la
moitié de la piste à fond voilà avant de
de les arrêter donc ils ont fait un
effort supplémentaire et à contretemps
après il est toujours très difficile de
repartir et n'oublions pas que le
démarreur est très jeune très prometteur
mais bon ça n'enlève rien à leur qualité
d'ailleurs qui s'est fait un petit peu
charrier par Michael delmeda qui est
dans le staff de cette équipe de France
l'ancien pisteur de l'équipe de France
qui lui a dit regarde tes collègues ils
ont des maillot de champion du monde ça
te fait quoi ça te fait quoi de les de
ne pas avoir ce maillot de champion du
monde alors que tu aurais pu la voir
peut-être en travaillant en plus bon ce
n'est que partie René il a 20 ans mais
ça prouve que cette équipe de France
veut gagner très jeune plein de talent
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
ce qu'il faut retenir alors c'est un
événement aussi qui a réuni le monde
entier journaliste photographe ou même
supporter était présent ils n'ont pas
hésité à faire le déplacement en garde
votre portage à ce sujet Michael
ils ont fait beaucoup de bruit dans les
tribunes hollandais belge ou encore
allemand les étrangers ont fait le
déplacement jusqu'au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
soutenir leur protéger pendant ces
mondiaux sur piste ouais mon fils on
sort ici pour trois jours pour supporter
les Belges
on a des médailles on espère qu'on a
avoir de plus je suis autrichien ma
femme est tellement
j'encourage la cause allemande
et vous pouvez entendre que j'ai perdu
ma voix
un peu plus loin on retrouve également
un supporter canadien qui a fait le
déplacement avec son grand chapeau il
est venu une journée sur place pour
supporter sa nièce c'était aussi pour
lui l'occasion de découvrir un vélo de
route de niveau international
je suis très impressionné par la vitesse
quand il y a une course
de ma vie et aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une réalité
dans l'air centrale des journalistes
venus des quatre coins de la planète
britannique américain encore japonais
sont présents dans ce vélo tourne
national pour relayer les informations
ici une cinquantaine de nationalité est
présente
je suis ici pour filmer et enregistrer
les interviews des cyclistes japonais
présent sur les Championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
n'est pas hyper populaire au Japon
mais on est ici pour promouvoir ce sport
et intéresser le public japonais
j'étais déjà là en 2015
je choisis des photos avec de l'action
je choisis des photos où on voit bien
les visages des coureurs j'ai choisi des
actions pour illustrer la course et
l'action sur la piste
supporters et journaliste ont pris leur
marque dans la structure 50e à
l'occasion de ces championnats du monde
tout le monde se retrouvera dans moins
de 2 ans l'occasion des Jeux olympiques
de Paris en 2024
et très rapidement Nicolas Michael c'est
facile de couvrir ses mondiaux facile au
niveau médiatique oui oui globalement on
a pu faire ce qu'on voulait dans ce vélo
de la semaine de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qu'on connaît
si bien on a pu notamment aller dans les
tribunes interviewer les supporters
comme comme on l'a vu au niveau de l'air
centrale c'était un peu plus restrictif
on n'avait pas trop le droit d'aller
dans les box pour déconcentrer on va
dire les pour ne pas déconcer les
athlètes murmit ça oui oui ça c'est bien
ça s'est bien passé on a pu faire le
maximum Nicolas moment chaud on l'a vu
tout à l'heure avec le clan gros
d'émotion mais voilà
et puis hâte d'être en 2024 parce que ça
donne vraiment envie d'assister à
quelque chose de grandiose parce que là
je pense que c'était un apéritif
il y avait 20 000 spectateurs c'est ce
que dit elle a Fédération française de
cyclisme et l'ucée sur ce championnat du
monde c'est championnats du monde une
chose qui est vraisemblablement la même
que celle en 2015 et ça c'est vraiment
rempli le weekend on va dire que le
weekend a sauvé un peu la semaine côté
public on a toujours du mal à démarrer
le premier jour donc en milieu de
semaine ça démarre c'est un peu un peu
timide mais après dès le vendredi et
c'était complet était rempli ouais
c'était Agif et ferme les Jeux
Olympiques ce sera pendant les vacances
d'été donc il y aura pas d'excuses
pour pour ce public très difficile
d'ailleurs d'obtenir des places mais on
le répète on l'a répété beaucoup de fois
c'était l'événement test on va dire
grandeur nature avant
belle répétitions réussite pour vous sur
le plan organisationnel de répétition
réussie une organisation toutes les
équipes de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme se sont mobilisés vraiment avec
un engouement puis ils ont apporté toute
leur compétences parce que il y a un
réel savoir-faire et ce sont ces équipes
qui seront également à l'oeuvre pour les
JO parce que la Fédération
sera maître d'oeuvre pour l'organisation
technique des JO en piste en BMX et en
VTT Nicolas André qui travaille à la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme m'a dit
qu'il fallait juste peaufiner sûrement
la sécurité forcément il y aura plus de
monde sur ces Jeux Olympiques il faudra
revoir le plan de la sécurité peut-être
les parkings aussi vont essayer de
trouver des solutions pour les parkings
en sachant qu'à Saint-Quentin il y a pas
qu'un seul site olympique exactement
voilà donc le parking qui qui était au
niveau du BMX par exemple devra sûrement
être
réorganisé enfin ils vont voir ça dans
les prochaines prochains mois et et
autres petites choses il travaille aussi
sur l'aspect spectacle de l'événement
c'est-à-dire qu'il pourrait baisser
peut-être la lumière au niveau des
tribunes pour qu'il n'y ait que la piste
d'éclairée d'accord vraiment mettre
l'accent sur les finales par exemple les
moments importants pour vraiment créer
une scénographie palpitante si je peux
dire probablement sur la 5G on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler mercredi avec
vous Nicolas mais dans tout ça un
maillon essentiel aussi dans cette
organisation c'est celui du bénévole des
centaines de bénévoles ont été présents
aussi sur ces mondiaux des bénévoles du
territoire parmi eux des retraités de
retraités plus précisément de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui s'appelle
tous les deux Jean-Paul vous les avez
rencontré Michael il fait partie des 250
bénévoles retenus pendant ces mondiaux
sur piste 2022 à 73 ans Jean-Paul de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux aide les
spectateurs à trouver leur place pendant
ce rendez-vous il a commencé le
bénévolat sur les événements sportifs
des Yvelines depuis une dizaine d'années
qu'est-ce qui me plaît déjà l'événement
lui-même le fait de pouvoir apporter
quelque chose aux sportif et le fait de
rencontrer beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
monde et dans un contexte comme celui-ci
des gens du monde entier comme je parle
anglais ça me permet aussi de dialoguer
d'échanger avec des gens d'un peu
partout son ami Jean-Paul lui aussi
originaire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
dans l'air centrale pendant la
compétition ce retraiter badge les
journalistes présents sur ces Mondiaux
les Villois commencent le bénévolat en
1989 il est aujourd'hui sur sa première
grosse compétition internationale
j'adore ça faire plaisir aux gens
transmettre et puis il faut des
bénévoles partout
j'étais arbitre de foot sans arbitre
même amateur il y a pas de match
bonjour il faut des bénévoles sur les
sorties scolaires surtout c'est
gratifiant quand même de sentir utile on
devrait revoir ces deux Jean-Paul en
2024 sur les différents sites zivinois
retenus pour les Jeux Olympiques de
Paris ils ont reçu la bonne nouvelle la
semaine dernière ils sont pour l'instant
sur la liste des bénévoles de
l'événement
oui maillon primordial les bénévoles ce
sera le cas aussi en 2024 essentiel
essentielle et sans ces bénévoles on ne
pourrait rien organiser même dans les
les petites compétitions ont besoin de
bénévoles et à plus forte raison les
grands événements et là faut voir
l'engouement et c'est le plus dans une
organisation mais sans eux on ne peut
pas c'est facile de les trouver où il y
a des difficultés aujourd'hui pour
trouver des bénévoles sur ce type
d'événements sur ce type d'événement je
veux dire c'est relativement facile à
une plateforme a été ouverte et là les
centaines de gens se sont inscrits voilà
et
idem pour les championnats du monde
paralympique
voilà où il faudra pratiquement autant
de bénévoles
bien sûr et est-ce qu'il faut aussi
s'attendre à des médailles françaises
j'espère que nous avons des des Français
très performants que ce soit en sprint
et et en endurance aussi
on y sera nous aussi à tv78 sur c'est
mondiaux de parasyclisme c'est
l'événement là qui arrive sur cette
semaine bien sûr on y sera donc ça sera
de ce jeudi jusqu'à dimanche il y a
quasiment le même nombre de nations un
petit peu moins de nations que sur ces
championnats du monde il y aura
également beaucoup de nations et c'est
gratuit aussi je le précise pour le
public si vous avez adoré les
championnats du monde au vu le don de
national de 50 ans en Yvelines vous
pouvez venir et c'est gratuit
Nicolas les championnats du monde
paralympique on suivra je l'espère en
2024 les jeux paraly qui sont aussi
importants que les Jeux Olympiques après
les Jeux Olympiques il y aura également
les Jeux paralympiques et le vélodrome
sera aussi l'une des enceintes pour ces
Jeux paralympiques voilà ce qu'on
pouvait vous dire sur le cyclisme sur
piste une longue page mais on y a passé
quand même 5 jours sur ces mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste on sait quand même
régaler sur sur ces cinq jours aller un
dernier tour de table c'est un événement
qui qui va rester peut-être la médaille
de Mathilde de gros la médaille d'or
c'est le moment peut-être moi qui me
vient tout de suite à l'esprit pour moi
aussi clairement c'est la médaille de
Mathilde de gros qu'on a vu débuter là
qui arrive avec cette magnifique
médaille d'or c'est le moment de la
confirmation forcément si ça c'est la
plus belle médaille pour moi mais il
faut surtout belle elles sont toutes
belles ces médailles c'est pour ça qu'on
aime le sport Grégory c'est quand on
voit des gens vibrer aux larmes comme la
famille de Mathilde gros c'est pour ça
qu'on aime le sport on a aussi quelques
larmes du côté de ben très ému
Jean-Michel la joie communicative de de
Marie divine alors là voilà elle aussi
enflammée le Vélodrome avec une
magnifique marseillaise aussi donc voilà
mais toutes les médailles sont belles
parce que c'est tellement difficile
d'aller chercher une médaille dans
toutes les disciplines aujourd'hui que
bravo et des records du monde ont été
battus aussi lors de ces Mondiaux
j'aurai l'occasion de reparler sur TV 78
un record du monde battu par Philippot
Ghana on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
plus tard merci Monsieur italien bien
sûr merci Jean-Michel richefort merci
président de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme merci à amicale et midoro et à
Nicolas dandry bravo pour cette
couverture et je rappelle que vous êtes
bien sûr journaliste de la rédaction TV
78 l'information à suivre également pour
la journée de demain je vous la rappelle
c'est cette grève j'en ai grève
interprofessionnelle à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats avec des
perturbations à prévoir dans vos
transports dans les Yvelines regardez
c'est prévisions ces trois trains sur 4
sur le RER et le RER B notez que sur le
RER B je vais y arriver l'interconnexion
est assurée à Gare du Nord RER C un
train sur deux tout comme sur la ligne N
du Transilien et enfin intrins sur trois
annoncé pour les lignes du Transilien JL
et U restez bien sûr informé sur les
sites de la SNCF et du Transilien à côté
météo on va jeter aussi un coup d'oeil à
vos conditions de ce mardi à 18 octobre
mardi 18 octobre nous fêterons les Lucs
des températures et des conditions de
météo homogène sur tout le territoire ce
sera nuageux pour le matin comptez 15
degrés dans les Yvelines le soleil
devrait faire quelques apparitions
l'après-midi mais avec toujours quelques
nuages il fera 20 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 19 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet les
températures assez hautes qui vont se
confirmer sur le reste de la semaine
même si la pluie est annoncée pour
vendredi voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité et on se
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
émission belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]